conchata farrell has died at the age of
77.
she was best known for her work on two
and a half men
you lied to me charlie
you said it was just going to be the two
of us she earned two emmy nominations
for outstanding supporting actress for
her role as berta on the show
mom lets me smoke oh well why didn't you
say so
no reason i shouldn't trust the judgment
of a woman who's off selling bootleg
metallica t-shirts at a monster truck
rally
she also had notable parts in movies
like erin brockovich and edward
scissorhands
[Music]
[Applause]
the actress had been long suffering from
health problems earlier this year she
was placed in a long-term care facility
following a heart attack
e.t had spent time with the star over
the years including
during the final season of two and a
half men i have to ask what are you
going to miss the most about coming to
this set well two things one is berta
i've gotten used to her i like keeping
company with her
i always like playing a character that
has something that i don't have
and she has a whole lot more husband
i'm going to miss her a lot and the
paycheck john cryer and charlie sheen
both paid tribute to their friend and
former co-star on twitter
charlie writing quote an absolute
sweetheart a consummate pro
a genuine friend a shocking and painful
loss
berta your housekeeping was a tad
suspect your people keeping
was perfect and john tweeting in part
quote i'm glad that i
absolutely knew how fortunate i was to
share a stage with her
i treasured every moment and will
continue to until we meet again
you